we're doing uh a fun rapid fire trivia
you're going up against your castmates
and your fellow thinkers okay
[Music]
okay so here we go and
action what
is robert de niro's famous line you
talking to me come from you talking to
me
are you talking to me
i don't goodfellas
next question where was aretha franklin
born
nashville tennessee national science
yeah that i don't know
next question rydell high school is the
setting for which influential 70s
musical movie greece is the word
yes yes i love it okay how many total
grammys did aretha franklin a lot
works for me
uh julie andrews won the best actress
oscar for which 1964 musical 64.
the hills are alive with the sound of
losing
i mean that should just give you a win
jody foster played fbi agent clarice
starling in what 1991
yes
okay question eight what was the first
feature animated movie released in
history
uh
to disney one
um snow white
uh yeah
you got it okay question nine which 90s
movie has the best selling sandwich of
all time you've got about 10 seconds
left
yeah i don't know hold on
pass what is your favorite aretha
franklin song ain't no way
i'll buy it great job i feel like we're
singing prowess she should get an extra
one
you